you are about to play I'm scared oh I am
you guys are I guess well um was that
supposed to happen
I put the look in here no folder folder
is empty
okay go hi whoa okay
how to play why are you why are you
doing that try to play the game wised
crouch control e when in danger
run hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to I'm
scared now this is I'm scared steam
Edition this game came out a long time
ago on games old but it rereleased on
Steam with even more terrifying dick a
tree that it calls game play so if you
remember I ski I'm scared from a long
time ago it was a game that messed with
you in many many ways and I'm assuming
that all of interact by pressing ok I'm
assuming it going to desktop was
intentional so I don't know what exactly
is different about this game collected
the gate key that's good or if
anything's different at all but this is
one of the original if not the original
pixelated style horror game that was
intentionally pixelated to amp up the
creep factor to extreme degrees so I
suppose there's a flower over there
crouched by pressing ctrl key and pick
it up do I wanna I wanna do so tiny you
collected oh I knew that was a mistake I
I had a funkalicious feeling that it was
gonna be a mistake and now I have a I
okay I have a flower that's what I have
don't know what I'm gonna do with this
flower but I got it
sure did turn night real quick out here
I do like that my house is on the edge
of the abyss that just piers off into
the nothingness Oh
oh hi hello ha I like a good joke - oh
I've it wealth okay made with yo-yo
games game maker studio okay I'm scared
a pixelated nightmare press e to begin
the experience err D to switch the menu
Oh achievements the first key peekaboo
master tag not to see heaven's door
question mark thanks for staying pika -
lucky tickets okay what happened why do
you do that
why do you keep doing that don't do that
why do you why do you keep going to my
desktop huh going into it Wow glad we
got the music kicking up already
I'm assuming that was me just slamming
my face on the keyboard so that it could
I could feel something control collected
a little key I got an achievement okay
all right that's good that was my what
was the point of that what was why why
did I use the little key on that was I
supposed to was that a necessity
hello okay we go down ladder I got
scared
ma now this seems familiar now it's been
so long since I played it that I
actually don't remember pretty much
anything to do with yeah I'm scared all
I remember is a scene in an underground
parking lot where the head chased me hi
and that's pretty much the long in the
short of it ye classic pixelated
bookshelf so uh hello
I collected a rusty key that's good I
feel positive about this I feel real
good about this
I think the ooze scooping out of the
walls is a good sign those locked so
it's got to either be a rusty door it's
something that's gonna get me on the
floor and everybody's gonna do the
dinosaur hello you could kick the noise
back up again oh hi hello how are you my
name is markiplier remember me don't go
okay
don't know why it is but it's awfully
quiet hello oh god Birds
[ __ ] it lay down take a nap that was
that was a thing okay
nothing in there glad I checked it glad
these are so scraping oh man it's moil
on this hinges i think bookshelf hello
how are you know do I jump I got a jump
for it oh no someone spilt strawberry
jam on my favorite painting okay I don't
know if I've used this rusty key yet oh
you're still in here all right okay
okay something's gonna happen it's gonna
happen I know I've been in there already
I just wanted to check to see it's a
rusty room
it's Rusty's room this isn't blood is
very damp rust I remember this
wait no I'm getting a flashback oh oh hi
no that didn't that doesn't look good
collected a pulsating hearts or
something by me there's somebody in
there
check to make sure the game is not
trying to deceive you if this is a new
installation ask your hardware software
manufacturer for hmm if you want to
restart your system press escape to
close gaming if you think something's
all right please restart the game Oh
[Music]
something's here attention okay there is
a way to turn an NTT into data they have
a life of their own it is difficult to
distinguish when we get the word wrap
here point them from normal computer
files in our actions of every day well
we sit at a computer this byte entity
observes us and studies our every move
in fear the game is simple to touch the
arrows is the key if you get caught you
lose a sound will predict its arrival it
is Whiteface attach the arrows is key if
you get caught you lose the game I guess
hello do you know my name oh yes it's
white face okay woo I don't know if I
got that right
see this is similar to the opening of
the first version of this game but
there's more to it I believe anyway oh
now playing car park okay all right
let's do this I remember the parking was
no bueno no indeed okay okay this is so
good okay good that's more like it
that's what I thought okay so what I got
to do there we go
it's open here we go I'm out of here
baby no
whoo easy as that easy as pie
easy as pie I didn't I toe
I forgot that I needed to get out of
here okay thank you I don't know why an
elevator released directly to a road
that doesn't make a lot of sense but
then again a lot a lot of things do well
I love watching you huh me too so do a
lot of people yeah mr. Whiteface you're
gonna have to fight with a lot of people
out there oh they love watching me hello
how are you doing hello my name is
markiplier oh yeah oh hey hey buy my
merch away what are you talking about
here whoa what how to play I'm scared to
play I'm scared you just have to think
outside the box to do so I have made an
example just for you
let's pretend that you're stuck in a
room and you need a heart to exit
looking around you'll find a key and
with the key you'll be able to open the
closet near the exit door
you won't find anything in the closet
it'll take some seconds though to
understand that while we were exploring
a path such as open behind you it takes
a small effort to be involved are you
brave enough baby boy I'm alone Obama
whoa baby
okay well that's that's lovely well I
don't know well I don't know I'm not a
hundred percent sure what what's going
on I'm suffering why why are you
suffering no okay nevermind then you're
suffering oh well this is taking a
detour that I didn't expect to be taking
but I'm still okay with it we're ever
going one of us them lying one of them
is lying not one of I'll follow this
this seems like a good idea they'll be
following a trail of blood that you
you're suffering well nothing I can do
about that and maybe it would did you
guys did you guys see the ground turn
all black and why not cuz I was just I'm
almost 100% sure that happened okay go
go back to the gate all right here we go
we won
is lying
I can't no I can't why can't I uh-huh
what can i huh whoa nice hole all right
how you doing
oh the painting someone cleaned up the
jam perfect do I still have that heart I
still do I still have that hard so hard
something in my possession you stuff it
in my pocket
do I have a pocket heart no if any heart
will do could I just use my heart Azusa
'ls robe is locked but there's no little
key anymore nope okay well alright here
we go
use the pulsating heart what is it just
squish it in my hand the end escape the
close game I don't think so wait a
minute
I don't think so you need to back that
up and try again cuz I know for a fact
that this ain't the end alright fine
[Music]
here's what I helped during game time
all righty then well okay there's a new
one
I'm sorry umm it's not gonna let you go
I shouldn't have told you to go on
follow my instructions don't let the
game's appearance deceive you from now
on if things change it arrives try take
some time and try to escape
alright okay let's try this again
oh now playing house I don't want to
play house now if that face in the
window
okay but I haven't been getting all the
achievements
I want the achievements
all the chief Nantz I think it's so
pretty I didn't expect that to actually
open all right
one eight two five okay that's not to
start slamming up indoors before I know
if they're about for one about you
Skoosh I collected some tongs are you
I got key number one I got the one key
all right so happy about this
all right well the one key doesn't work
on any of the other numbers which is
shocking to me but also okay one I did
it
yeah my free oh hello am I free okay
there's nothing here why did wide by why
wait find ah oh
key number why is it dark my name is
markiplier yep you're shocked at how
yeah it's me don't worry I'm just the
human I'm not don't call me a hero I I
know alright I got number eight key
whatever that means
what could it possibly mean I don't even
understand eight whoa I didn't mean to
do that
who what huh why who did what who didn't
mean to do one eight right I got eight
I've also got some tongs
watch out very long wardrobe is low hey
who's the ticky tacky hello oh wait wait
a minute wait this was this wasn't open
before
damnit oh you better get back here [ __ ]
hey come here come here get him over
here you say that [ __ ] to my face I'm
turning my back on you which seems like
a very intelligent decision to do oh oh
there's blood in there now
great oh did you do that is that my
blood did I trail that in somehow
alright that's locked number seven oh
good
help me I don't want to die well I'm
scared oh why was there blood in here
alright seven oh hi hello this is my
room nice room
love what you've done do you see how
dark it is no you can't see darkness
it's cold but I can look at you oh yeah
why are you gettin close away look I'm
not gon look at you
come on staring contest are you scared
No look at these muscles how can these
muscles be scared you better back off oh
I am scared okay well you didn't get me
you tried real hard and you failed what
is going on here alright
some kind of Jackson Pollock situation
going on here
why is it only in my right ear I don't
like that oh god I'm so good know why
that's happening I left here now lucky
number - oh that tingles in my brain Wow
tingling in my brain okay number two
there's something heaven's door wait
what did what did I just do I just did
something I got an achievement for
something but I don't know what I did -
I like the squishy just the way I like
my rooms Oh No key number six do I get
key number six looking key number six
like oh hey maybe I shouldn't come in
this room no okay hello
am I about to regret something hello hi
oh okay I just went around the way oh
I'm back freedom freedom freedom free
freedom freedom Oh freedom freedom
congratulations oh you made it to the
end but you can't escape from here stay
with me I will always be here looking at
you yeah I'm okay oh yeah I'll see you
I'll see you I'll see you goodbye
goodbye yeah see ya dude hey dude just
gonna take a nap
it's gonna let's go go down the hall
nope can't do that either
okay let's go back back the way I came
that sounds good oh okay that don't work
here
alright that's that's bizarre wait what
the hell do I see can I see it all the
way from where I'm at now we'll always
be here something's missing
alright whatever I'm afraid I can't let
you do that feed me share me play with
me I'm yours that is kinky the end I
have a lot of names one of them is her
wait wait a minute wait a minute one of
a lot of names one of them is her wait a
minute
wait what is zero it's alive it's real
it's changing again like the last time
what form will it take it's just a
phantom of deception yeah you're goddamn
right yeah you're goddamn right it is
that's not the end that might have been
the end of the original game but that's
not the end of this one here there's
others
I know this no notice I'm not gonna look
up a walkthrough just yet oh wait the
doors still open ooh wait I load it back
in it's the beginning of the game but
the store is open now we need a heart in
order to open it there's no key down
there anymore
there is scary
there's something to this there's
something to this oh you're open
why are you open is there a heart
already here hmm bizarre lying taking
that heart yet I need to see what's
going on around here oh never mind
SpaghettiOs I guess we're taking the
heart then oops
ah now what I had in mind oh you there
oh you did it again damn it okay that's
fine going back in hello do you know my
name her your name is her why is there
just a boy
all right okay mmm playing cop okay what
does that say wait what does that say
please be quiet
please be quiet please be quiet how do I
be quiet
oh whoa whoa wait a minute
wait whoa hey wait a minute Danny right
you can't just um the dingdong Bing bong
did leading don't please be quiet how to
play okay I'm still just as funky and
loud as I was before
well just keep going eh whoa got me okay
that's nice oh okay that's that's real
nice
what are these pictures supposed to be
is it uh is it mr. whiteface watching me
let me see what's down here first okay
all right now that I've sort of I ain't
gonna be quiet I'm gonna be raucous be
loud I got the piano key does it what is
it unlock all right
anyway I'm assuming that I should not
run in order to be quiet right okay what
was the point of coming in here okay Oh
what happens if I run I really want to
know what happens if I run I'm really
quite curious to know what happens if I
run
series of always know what happens if I
rode running what did you do about it
running in the hallways okay what
happens if I just loop through this
hallway a whole bunch of times I mean
it's probably not gonna do anything but
there's always a chance so I'm gonna
dedicate a minute to this oh oh oh uh
obviously her I know her hello her how
are you doing where the door is locked
alright what the hell what the hell did
I just do hmm okay well I did something
clicking on the painting did something I
don't know what it did but it did
something
whoa open this up okay I thought this
was gonna be something like that I
thought I saw some scrape he's on the
ground hi how are you I'm tempted to say
hi but somehow I imagine that's gonna
end my demise alright well I might have
a mistake that might have that might
have been a mistake whoopsies oh it is
oh it is Oh smarty smarty okay so let's
just uh oh
[Music]
oh I need a rope dog sighs yeah I don't
want to climb - no no no that I'd want
that I can't even open that oh so I had
to die
oh good I don't even know if I died
really it's kind of just like a reality
looping thing huh
have you really think about it okay so I
am only imagine that this one opens up
the door that was in the hidden alcove
over you are over right oh dang cuz I
had dreamed Oh with all of grandmas
knickknacks oh boy can i play a game of
pool
okay anymore her hey Bo ho ho sighs okay
so it's a pool puzzle can I run now I'm
a run now I'm a run okay so there's a
puzzle going on here okay so blue - oh
okay green 14 red 11 blue - okay yellow
one blue to red 11 green 14 easy-peasy
I think green 14 blue to yellow one was
11 but that's wait a minute
[Music]
there's four there's four of those
there's one of you there were two blues
[Music]
okay I'm sorry my memories so good
I apologize who's crying Wow who's a big
little baby Paul who's got the way we're
too much up in this game mommy mommy
that's for sure oh don't touch me oh I
want to touch you her touch okay all
right then well
[Music]
ggg-go chief got an achievement
apparently she's gonna skedaddle I'm not
even gonna nope no I'm gonna look not
gonna look oh gosh don't need to go I
still need to go
what the hell what a bunch of oh oh no
oh no okay all right
what close here close here close here
closer close here what is it wait
there's an achievement there close here
hold here close here what does that mean
ah it's there something's there the
achievement is telling me something says
there's something here what
escape oh-oh escape clothes here oh I
did a corkscrew well that's nice but I
got the rope and that's all I'm asking
let's see if let me see if there's still
something out here can I run now can I
run that run could I be loud and
obnoxious now okay you know what I'm
just gonna go for it go for it run e1e
style I still don't know why this door
don't work about this door all right
well I'm gonna go for it
all right here we go you used rope good
mium use rope real good mium know how
rope be used oh boy hedge maze okay nice
is gonna have to remember any of this
no I am going to have to remember this
aren't I oh no oh I found a way to help
you while in game reduce the window with
f4 key and check the game folder for
here dot txt the solution lies there oh
that's why it goes all small ok I'm
sorry Lockwood oh he got you here here
it's a map it's a map it's a map oh
that's a nice map that's a nice map I'm
sorry
Locke Locke Kedah I don't know what that
means
well ok now let's go back big uns ok ok
all right let's do this wait you know
I'm backwards let's do this let's do
this all right where am I going
I'm already lost oh I know where to go
wait I got this okay this is yeah okay
that's that but then what's all the plus
e minus bull honkey thing going on I
think this helps me why do they give me
a map I don't really need a map slide I
need a slide like slot slides cool okay
the gate is locked okay why am I here
what is this map for oh wait there's a
there's a youtube link
[Music]
Oh
oh it's a hidden passage oh I get it
oh okay that's what oh that's why the
map is there because the map actually
the map shows the hidden passage right
there in front of it I if I'd looked at
it I would have seen it but I didn't
because I'm stupid all right hidden
passage were laughs that video was fun
on a bun there we go
got it nailed it I am real smart Oh
yourself oh oh
real one oh real one oh don't be
deceived the other one is lying from now
on follow the instructions of this html4
it is trying to deceive you one more
time follow the map you'll find a key
with that key you'll be able to destroy
the lock in your game folder there's
keeping the green gate locked almost
forgot this list will be useful later
you'll find in the mirror oh my god oh
god oh god oh god that's a lot of okay
alright put that there it's uh alrighty
then thank you for your assistance
there's another secret passage this
one's definitely not alive it's right
here yeah okay alright well I'm not
gonna follow the blood I'm gonna go the
opposite way of the blood because whoa
what what what why did what I mean what
am I looking at
ah okay all right okay weird okay oh
I'll get it collected the labyrinth key
rate to you is there any more secret
passageways that you guys want to tell
me about some kind of like secret nooks
and or crannies okay nope okay that's
not the right thing so there's got to be
something else
okay so I got the labyrinth you said
something about a lock what does that
say that say what if I just wait the
lock is literally a text file locked
let's make this hangar with unlocked got
it save that file save close that out
open this up right now nope gate is
locked how about we delete it
don't wait that got it cool got it
alright that's been deleted Oh
easy peasy me I'm smarty wardi insert
mirror code two on the Left two on the
right two on the Left okay I saw you
come on don't be coy get back here you
little scamp
oh nice uh nice hole look at the mirror
looking at the mirror I think look at
the mirror okay alright
okay all right I don't know what that
was all about but okay all right well
let's go oh man am i stuck oh wait I can
see oh I can see through you
oh that's weird
well that's real weird okay that's
bizarre
why can I see through you okay that's
handy-dandy
oh you got the mannequin / corpse of a
corpse of looky-loos which is awfully
nice alright okay maybe if I I'm gonna
do something I'm gonna activate you
maybe now the mirror quote-unquote is
there
mirror mirror mirror on the wall wait a
minute wait where am I now
Oh why'd you stop oh thank you for the
shard of the mirror I don't understand
what that was about but thank you very
much so I was able to pass through Oh
another oh hey how's it going how you
doing hello baby
good okay hello baby
okay all right thank you
okay so I think what this does is it
allows me to pass through the gates
unhindered okay where do I need to go oh
wait - on the left - on the right that I
got the two on the left I already did
that whoo so I just need to go to the
two on the right okay all right so
there's got to be a way to get back okay
so that's out but this is right so it's
got to be over here somewhere here
there's something that I need what am I
looking at help me
click to the short of the mirror barely
okay well good for me
let's try this again um alright I've got
to find a shard of the mirror hello
wait you're back here oh okay so there's
another one on the left where is another
one somewhere here maybe it's in maybe
it's in the normal the normal world of
this left area that's got to be it right
beside get my bearings a bit more now
that I can see things it's got to be
somewhere around you all this was locked
down there's nothing there
oh I was right I was right okay I was
right okay so I got to go get back into
the Shadow Realm the upside down a and
uh die and then I'm good to go I think I
just need to get over here go to the
lady who is able to get me back out
right here hello thank you for that
weird mannequin I'm gonna assume a
mannequin and not a corpse okay here we
go I got him okay look at the mirror I'm
looking at it what if I look at the
mirror in the opposite world
gonna do anything for me oh you dick you
dick
you dick your dick what did that say
what did that say on the ground in there
oh you're going Oh whose mannequin lady
oh I see okay all right I looked at your
mirror okay all right that did it I
typed in the secret code okay there's
got to be something I had to happen now
right please laugh more I'll do try not
to laughs when I feel like it not when
you demand it input numbers and then
press e please laugh more is that like
one of these codes please laugh more ah
that is one of them please laugh more oh
okay here we go five one nine four seven
all right is it possessive oh alright
okay use the Oh the labyrinth key
blood blood
all right let's in here again okay
so just in case because I feel like it
I'm gonna try these again make sure
there's nothing in here oh wow
wowie wowie wowie wowie wowie I knew it
I knew it I knew it
oh boy why did I go in here what is the
bad move all around
okay if we're fine we're totally fine
everything is a hundred percent
hunky-dory
everything is Gucci the floor is nice
let's run you I get jump like that not
that again
what Oh white dogs will frickin hello
okay bye alright well then see you see
you buddy okay this is our why hi hello
you're lovely are you are okay I don't
know what I'm looking for here
wait oh oh that thing's it oh that's
that's it hear that oh oh no oh no oh no
oh no okay I don't know what that's all
about and I don't know what that sounded
the thing that's in here is why I'm
gonna find out I guess I'm coming for
you maybe maybe it's just in my head
it's very directional so I'm assuming
that it's okay listen lady listen listen
lady lady lady listen listen lady lady
listen
[Music]
oh what the hell oh whoa oh I got a
gramophone it's nice so uh so what about
that how big is this place I can't tell
where anything is
oh there you are oh whoa whoa she's fast
okay all right ah so you can kind of go
towards the sound
it's kind of hard this is weird one this
is weird
oh oh okay yeah I did it I think that
was weird that took me a while to get I
don't know why but it did okay all right
thank you thank you was this exit the
whole air the whole time oh thank you
got the Metro key good I was hoping for
this what is where are we going wait was
the way I was supposed to go if this is
where I came from
where did they come from where did I go
where did I come from cotton-eye Joe the
elevator no the answer is a big no one
that way so it's got to be the hallway
that was new which would have been
logical but I just want to make sure
that I wasn't on the wrong way because I
don't want to get lost not this deep
into the game anyway
oh the meadow
15:25 okay all right that is the current
time that is that is indeed the current
time Oh what do you want me to do train
schedule oh so I you're gonna make me
change the time oh okay all right I'll
change the date and time oh I'll do that
oh if you're so smart about it I'll do
it all right it's Oh Oh
thank you for the ticket thank you thank
you we got a bed - oh that's a quiet
train
oh you're reaching oh oh a bad okay no
no like that okay I hope you reach this
sign in a minute there's a new file on
the desktop but I know I know it wants
to destroy it I hope it's still there if
not I'm sorry right will nope the real
one
nope that was okay there's no well I
push the button - dad did that do
something did that put a file there no
it did not
so uh push the button hopefully pushing
that button was a good thing and not a
bad thing oh yeah all right I push the
button I'm real good at the button
pushing game I'm gob the best button
pushing honk all right okay no no no
it's going in here why me why am I going
back and forth on these buttons good
check my fist up again nope nothing
gee
[Music]
okay all right this load is that bigger
is that that one bigger is that a bigger
hump boy that love definitely getting
bigger how are you doing how you doing
it
you good you good okay all right how's
that hump it's gone it popped all right
come and face the truth okay
all right sure Oh whatever you say I'm
uh I'm game
can I go was weird all right okay hello
hello all right how you doing hey we
crashed I mean it closed it on me it's
not really a crash is it okay I am a
liar why you're a liar why are you a
liar oh so this is goodbye
if things go as I think you'll have to
shoot with the left click of the mouse
but I have to say I don't think it will
give you bullets I'm sorry
six will do okay all right well I don't
know who's talking to what here what
kind of conversation is going on I don't
much appreciate it
and I okay I'll just I'll just keep
walking straight forward then huh
all right I don't know what's happening
but I like it
hello okay Oh her you made me think
about life who who made who think about
what about appearance I changed bit by
bit
hahaha
I really did like what happened to me
you want this whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
then kill me in front of my wife Oh
reload oh you didn't give me bullets
yeah
where are there bullets out there oh
well that's a problem there's a problem
problem
oh I'll jump in the hole nope okay bang
Bob oh there's a revolver file bullets
six
let's put six bullets in that bad boy
let's load up this game again all right
get ready to throw down come on now you
want some of this huh you want some of
this huh you want some of this oh yeah
that's right yeah boom banging banging a
boom a bang Oh Bob or get more distance
bang I miss bang whoa
oh whoa
[Music]
I was white face the whole time but who
was her again very maybe that is my name
oh wait
Ivan Zhanna Lottie wait oh okay hello
hello how are you do you want me to
still be quiet what about that door that
didn't open woah
oh game handy game ended I don't know
what that means okay
oh okay there's a new folder layer the
curtain falls I want to share a story
with you why is he capitalized I've
never had the chance to be a child but
when I was a child I always thought
about awful things one day my brother
went to an appliance store leaving me in
the back seat of the car I looked at him
entering the store disappearing behind
the sliding doors then my head drew
scenery oh no my brother got impaled by
some sort of electrical appliance
there's blood everywhere what should I
do now the truth is I never had a
brother as her to talk was not my thing
I just wanted to entertain you maybe I
should go back your change again you
changed me and now I'm not scared no I'm
worried maybe that's why I'm using all
these comets I never liked that much
maybe I'll let you play with me for a
short time instead of the opposite I
have two more secrets for you the
credits hold one of them it will be fun
was that the name of the dude I've been
asana Thani wasn't it Ivan zanotti Ivan
zan naughty with two t's oh boy hang on
now Ivan zanotti we have to try that
name into the name thing hell yeah we're
still here you just got to go get the
heart loud
wild blonde blend log blam blam Ivan
well why
ah here we go Ivan Zen auntie did I do
it
is that right what is this
oh we're big now okay we're in a grocery
store oh is this the appliance store
check the to-do list okay I'll do I'll
do I'll do that all right
this reality will never collide with the
other but the events of one alters the
twin and vice versa have you already
tried resetting see what's on the other
side tomorrow's your turn don't forget
to freeze check the freeze room send
mail send market orders with the
computer fix the electrical panel if the
PC gives problems just turn it off if
you don't find the office keys I'll send
someone with them as soon as you send
the letter okay a little weird bizarre
but okay check the freeze room okay I
can feel the wind crawling under the
door what does that mean it's the market
electrical panel okay where's how do I
get in the freeze room got the
refrigerator key I didn't even know it
was there
whoa got a letter okay why is that just
floating in mid-air okay so I got a mail
the letter that all I got to do I got to
do that all right
weird mail you have a glimpse of the
outside yeah you're damn right I do
throw this away it's an empty trash bin
there's got to be a way to send this
letter I'm not a hundred percent sure
how or why or what it's trying to get me
to do
[Music]
Oh slip the letter under the door
oh well good now someone's gonna give me
a key probably I don't understand how
that works but okay anybody gonna give
me a key so slipper slipper slipper
slappy slip me a key slip a slum Post
let me that sweet sweet key hello let's
let's close and get back in oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm I'm outside no
it's garbage okay oh oh oh see what's on
the other side I get it
Oh electrical wires okay that's Oh so
when you reset it you go into the other
side that makes sense okay so I got to
put the letter even farther away black
blink sent the letter I did it I sent it
I really say you have a glimpse of the
inside well it's Gollum see wimzie back
in and Audi Wow D all right we're in Oh
Keith thank you all right I got the
office key that was a thing all right
well let's go in here what's these a
cutter great press e to send data okay
do i reboot is that my computer or is
that you're talking about something else
or what you talking about which talk
about we should talk about maybe I need
to um I've got a cutter now so maybe I
need to cut some wires in the bank I
don't know if that'd be the best idea
but the only way to restart the computer
I'm not gonna restart my computer
they're talking about my computer I
don't want to reboot I'm recording I'm
just stand up I don't want to stand it
you have a glimpse of the other side
wait what does that do
wait the cutter is in the trash there's
the wait no if I go away if I wait no if
I if the cutter is in the trash will it
show up in the garbage
oh okay now now I can cut the electrical
wires right I mean that's the equivalent
of fixing it right just smashing up
everything in there and crossing the
wires all over the place Oh cut
everything that's good right oh it's
dark oh no oh it's gonna be dark in
there I don't know if that's the
equivalent of fixing it before I have a
glimpse of the inside I don't know I
don't know that I have as much of
glimpse as you think I do I think I have
exactly none glimpse but that's okay cuz
now I have a way in I think anyway hey
this
hate this oh no no let's just okay let's
just carefully scan around data sent oh
oh that's how you reboot it okay okay I
guess we're done then all done
let's get EOD again and let's get he
back any weight Oh
enter it oh my god enter a great place
what is this instructions oh it's really
fun but you're reaching a point of no
return please stop I don't want to die I
want to help you
ooh what do we have here some secret
secrets that need to be secret
[Music]
[Music]
did anybody write a comment of it try
asking me this I don't know what that
means
cool all right well take me to the door
sure okay let's just okay all right
oh I get it these would be letters
oh they're letters of the alphabet okay
take me to the door whatever the heck
that means sure okay take me to the door
[Music]
take me to the door take me to do it the
Dozen you mean the heart you don't hurt
or one of these doors
oh is that open you're talking about
oh you station key
it's weird I still have everything he's
labyrinth key it's really weird
okay door you I just checking everything
just in case skooshy I'm gonna take you
to the door
nope okay guess I can't take it to the
door ah take me to the door okay take me
to the door that's not my name maybe you
misspelled it don't forget I'm
case-sensitive seventeen seven four nine
fifteen nine seventeen thirteen
seventeen twenty nine to thirteen
thirteen one let's try that it's not my
name okay ditch maybe it's lowercase
okay that worked ok it was lowercase
which is weird I thought it would have
been oh I thought it would have been oh
we got a leak okay well this is weird
what the hell is this place it is locked
okay well that's understandable okay
this is probably locked
okay that's also understandable it is no
game
we got announced there what Ellis's huh
pipes a alright I've committed this to
my memory I've inserted it into my brain
I know this so incredibly well no one
can stop me
alright what do I do with that alright
well there's a lot of steam here okay
whoa
Kerr chuckles that's good right hey hi
do you do you want
[Music]
do I want to I'd build a snowman dude a
little hook like a little snake tongue
coming out blue all right you're cute
you're cute you're cute you're adorable
but I got a valve and apparently someone
wants to build a snowman with me which
is real cool I like that a lot
okay so there's got to be like a place
to put the valve never that would be
there's a hole here well good news for
me I've got us something what all right
okay I got valve a doesn't do nothing I
can stick my head in and notice that's
weird okay oh it opened yay all right
that's good to know
whoa pipes be oh I've got this in my
brain oh oh I got it okay I've got it
committed so memory got it okay uh-huh
got it no no no no I go I can't run oh
okay I see
okay all right you rogue let's try this
squirted hello oh that was bad thing
that was bad that was a bad thing okay
all right well okay then good I see
their arrows so they are errors okay so
I know what no way I just need to get
back to the middle one all right let's
try this I'm gonna go all the way around
oh hey buddy yeah don't know why they're
making paintings of you that's weird
oh I can't go that way all right I don't
like the whistling oh I really don't
like Donald like the whistling okay
we're gonna good ah oh we don't know
what do we do what do you think you're
doing okay I am almost there and made it
nice nice nice I did it I'm waiting okay
good for you I don't care I got the
valve I got the valve and that's all
that matters okay I did it uncle let's
try the last one all right let's do this
got it do it I am behind you
no no way no no no okay pipes ooh I like
the way this one goes that's what goes
in a fun direction but I guess I can't
go that way
Wow whoa Wow okay the shift key is
broken
what about the other shift key no no it
seems to be broken
okay turn on sticky keys accidentally
all right well that's no good
um okay well giant man oh okay
it's a race or something do I need to
beat you you're kind of slow so this
ain't so bad just pick up that looks
like one of the keys for the for the
doors that are numbered in the beginning
of the game look at the parking lot Oh
fixed thank you thank you for fixing it
thank you oh did I do it liar liar I
don't know what that says I can't Shack
let's see oh I didn't see that one okay
you're a big you're big ah titty
sprinkles oh dang dong all right where
we going what are we doing there good
catch hello that what I needed
whoa okay I guess that's what I needed
got it okay that's the first time a bit
that kind of thing happened to me got it
oh it's very heavy oh it's real heavy
hello this thing is okay nailed it I
think
I can't
okay
do I need
again man this game wants you to quit a
lot let's try her again I bet something
that felt like something bugged out it
didn't feel like I actually didn't get
that that felt like something just
bugged oh wait what okay suddenly I'm
able to move normally now that was oh
that was weird he must have just been a
bug must have just been of this valve is
really heavy bug like that kind of thing
I don't know why that happened but it
did okay I'm on you know uh no no you
ain't
not anymore cuz I got the last valve and
I don't know what I'm gonna do with it
but I'm gonna stick it in here you
haven't unlocked all the achievement
please restart the excuse you
excuse you excuse you what the hell
oh you sack of tits you said I didn't
know okay I guess we're I guess we got
to do it I guess we got to get all of
the achievements I've looked up how to
do it and one of them is random chance
which kind of sucks but okay ah here we
go
hello hello
and there we go peekaboo
got it peek-a-boo peek-a-boo okay so I
got peekaboo now what I need to do is
get the not a see not to see thing which
is just you got a restart and then you
have to play through the white face part
and just see if you get it
mmm this is weird you shouldn't be here
oh I shouldn't be here huh
well I am whew not to see ahaha I got
that it whoa whoa what does a key whoa
hi whoa what the heck in heck is that a
super weird
all right GLaDOS oh hey the gramophone
is broken oh hey you're smiling now are
you doing your good alright cool great
oh wow I really shouldn't be here yeah
okay
alright well this is fun I'm glad do
this alrighty then okay oh what's over
here okay so now I go through the her
section again I need pika - and lucky
tickets that's what I need so pika - and
lucky tickets not hard but the her
segment did take a lot longer
[Music]
what wait what wait whoa but um that's
not
how did
what wait a minute no that's what I need
to play through this segment again how
do i you have to let me through again I
need to go through again I need to go
through again why is this just
ah I got it okay I changed one value in
the in the in the the achievement things
I've changed one thing so I should start
right here and I spin though all right
so I'm here so I just got to play
through this section again which is a
long one admittedly it's a long one but
that doesn't mean that I can't do what I
need to do the door's locked
hello beautiful how you doing how you
doing but now that I know all the
secrets I should be able to get there
pretty quickly
all without sprinting so I'll be back
once I get to the places I need to go
yeah I did it I Scott cheated a bit but
I did it okay we're back here here comes
the what we need here we go yeah yeah
give me that give me that chief man give
me the chief give me the pika - there we
go
okay got pika - what did I need to do
here remember definitely not that oh god
damn it oh my god okay last one baby
okay we need 7:45 was it
we need 7:45 a.m. okay 7:45 a.m. nice
okay and then 823 oh lucky ticket okay
lucky tickets got it that is the last
achievement so all I got to do is finish
this out then I can reset and then I can
go where I need to go right that's all
there is to it
Oh
oh yeah okay all sides pump good okay
good ball good bong
oh good bomb good one good one good one
bonk all right good [ __ ] off good form
good bump on that go up good bump great
bump
fastball fastest bump okay here we go
face the end oh oh oh I'm white face all
right and the last of the game the
ending that we've been looking for we
got all the achievements I know that for
a fact
so all we got to do is we got to go down
here we go into the door we were able to
go into it because of the oxidated key
not the rusty key with the oxidated key
and then once we're here we'll see what
this is all about we've got all the
valves
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's just a black screen
oh oh sorry what
- okay it's just darkness oh oh okay
hello how are you
hello welcome to the door this is your
last choice if you enter this door our
game will end for real please please
please pick up the flower and give it to
me I will reset everything we did until
now I don't know this whole adventure
started by me picking a flower and then
you set me down into a world of hurt and
pain some tells me I should probably
just go through the door I don't want to
reset everything we did until now I want
to go through the door do you really
want to open it choose wisely for it is
irreversible yeah I'll go through it
oh oh um um bah Oh little key
he wasn't too happy about that there's a
just a folder called white face now but
there's nothing in it let's try loading
it up one more time he's not happy today
is that what happens if we load it up
every time no oh okay he's not he's not
happy he's not a happy camper
not happy oh you don't even deserve to
be touched
oh well that's pretty rude that's pretty
rude okay just let me just touch all
over everything else I'm do chit it I'm
do Chi touching everything all right
I'll be back here I go back I go just
die already
nap I'm good I begged you and you
ignored my request well you know goods
whatever you know willow all right well
marty'll wait okay all right yeah oh I
can't okay what about this all right
well all right let's go back in let's do
it again you can't kill me [ __ ]
Lizzy I'm scared yeah you should be
scared of me Oh heart thank you
no mm-hmm okay why is there a heart here
nope dead hard no no all right you're
gonna were me you're gonna roar at me
hmm is there something in the folder Oh
heart ooh okay I suppose you're
satisfied I'm scared I am scared at the
point that I cannot hide my heart
anymore destroy this file move it change
its name the game will end and so will
my curse leave me here I beg you I do I
want to stay here with you just a little
more just a little more but I do know
farewell
okay goodbye Oh achievement unlocked
loneliness oh I'm scared the end oh very
interesting sorry didn't realize I could
go up Ian Downey I'm gonna go down II I
guess why can I go down here okay that
leads to that everything seems different
okay this is there's no hard anymore no
hole anymore everything seems different
it's super bright I don't like it that's
nice can I go oh everything's super
bright that's weird is weird
guys this is there's a little bizarre
hello you weren't there before
Mirror Mirror oh okay this is a little
this is a little perturb Euler I'm a
little confess old by this no doors here
I guess where's that secret where's this
secret no nothing nothing nothing I
don't know if I trust this is just a
little too bizarre very odd No oh
there's no rope okay
guess that did nothing is weird this is
super weird Holopainen oh there's
where's that go was this it was this the
grave oh that's that said something just
to share in a new spy grave weird
anything in there nothing there's always
someone I checked before oh I'm not
giving up on you okay I should have
given up on you okay
well oh oh well I can finally go across
the area oh what's the highway okay
alright alright can I even go here in
the parking lot again
oh I can't oh it only lets me in the
elevator it doesn't let me go down okay
this is just bizarre it's just
everything is in broad daylight no no
curtains although the rendering is here
nothing else do it the whole world has
been torn apart okay is
can I go to the train station I don't
even know why I'm bothering to go
everywhere okay oh this place Oh God Oh
Oh God it just goes to the train station
does the train station go anywhere and I
use the ticket that's nope okay all
right on the side nope have a nice day
okay
it's just empty okay I think this might
actually be the end there's nothing else
to do because there's no white face
anymore there's no her anymore
it's just that's it all the well the
magic is gone the seers all this books
just all gone okay well I uh yes that's
it let me just try to restart one more
time but I'm pretty sure that's all
that's gonna happen okay that's it I
think that's it
holy [ __ ] that was awesome that was an
experienced LA man I love that honestly
I love that
going from I'm scared being one of the
first games that I played on my channel
like in 2012 I played the first version
of this game to now or I'm able to 100%
the entire game and see all the
mysteries behind it and still be left
with questions I don't know fully
understand if it wasn't happening here
but it's still tons of fun so thank you
everybody so much for joining me on this
journey thank you for like if this made
you 'test alg ik like for the old video
way way way back when I'll put the link
to that video in the description down
there below but let me know what you
thought down in the comments and just
thank you everybody so much for being
here it's cool to see this come full
circle even if I could have played it
two years ago but just to see it come
full circle is just really really cool
and yeah I wouldn't trade that feeling
for the world so thank you everybody so
much for watching if there are any other
secrets that you want to find in this
game or you know about you can play this
game it's on Steam I'll put a link to
the description linking to it in the
description as well also we're going to
Australia and obviously Amsterdam so
check out the dates for those
Tuerto markiplier comm there will be a
link to that in the description as well
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always see you in the next video
[Music]